[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen i'm mitzi
bananamore and i'm here to kibbitz with
none other than multi-talented
so many things to list it's too many to
list so we'll just say it's kiki palmer
hello
it's so wonderful to be here with you
what in the hell twits do you ever sleep
you know i ask myself that question all
the time you know
what box are you gonna check today well
i can tell you it's been a long time for
me waiting to sit down with you so i
definitely think i'm gonna be able to
check that box off you know i'm equal
opportunity i go both ways so don't
flirt with me because you might end up
in bed with me
all right and i like to make everybody
feel good if you know what i mean
i'm a real cat in the sack i'm just
saying oh speaking of uh sex i hear you
have to sleep in a pitch-black room why
well you know what i like to do that
because it it it's something that you
know melinda's are doing lately we're
just trying to like really keep
everything kind of low key chill get the
spirit going and if you apparently just
sleep like pitch black you know what i
mean no barely any phone furniture you
like really being one with the earth i
feel the exact opposite you know when
i'm in that casket it's gonna be real
dark so i need like bright lights i need
to see the sun come up the pitch
blackness it scares me out of me whoa
even when i blink i'm like oh what's
there you know i need bright i need
light really really that must have been
tough growing up you dream of doing
stand-up one day i gotta say
i got a club for you i got a stage i'd
love to honor you
why do you want to do stand-up what's
the intention behind it this is the
thing i don't see myself probably doing
it i would see myself doing it in a very
different way you know i would try to
really bring me to it but the thing i
like about it is that i'm performing in
front of an audience and that i can give
some type of social commentary and you
know express how i feel about it but in
a way that can be you know light-hearted
and fun you know because i think
sometimes there's so many things i
always want to talk about but i find my
strength in being able to say it when i
put it in with comedy well you know
you've come up with all these amazing
characters
right you know one after the other
that's why
i bet you do need a blackout curtain
probably to shut the ideas off it's like
a
leaky faucet it's true you know idea
drip idea drip when you're coming up
with a character do you see the
beginning the middle the end and sort of
color within the lines do you write the
scripts what's the process you know i'm
sure there's a lot of people out there
who would like to have the cojones
to create characters but what's your
advice to them what's your process you
know i start with a concept in my mind
like i'll start with you know a certain
point of view that i want to understand
you know about a character maybe this is
a person that what would it be like if
you grew up with no parents and you just
you know you just were always solo all
your life what kind of person would that
make you
then i this is the result of no parents
really yeah and what is the voice you
have such a unique voice what's the
history of that a lot of smoking yeah
yeah and that'll do it yeah yeah i
wouldn't advise anyone to live the way i
do but it's my life i want to ask
everybody what makes them tick so you
come up with a character yeah yeah and
you know when you walk down the street
and you see someone it could there be
inspo there oh yeah if you watch
something could there be in spawn there
oh yes do you think of like a memory or
a person and you think i'd like to
extrapolate on that i want to make it
come to light yeah i used to think i
created this character chelsea barbie
taylor one time i called my producing
partner and i said you know what would
you what would it be like who if i was
angelina jolie and brad pitt's black
daughter what would i sound like what
would i be like what would be the
what would be the reality of that how
could we
change the conversation where as it
pertains to culture identity and race
how can we flip it on his head with a
character like that well that was going
to be my next question because after our
life long riddled with offending people
so sorry god you're so sensitive comedy
is not for the faint of heart exactly
tootsie we're on the same wavelength and
i'm wondering how
do you draw the lines because i want to
know what your process is when it
returns to my art i'm always going to
say this is a character you know this is
i'm i'm acting or i'm performing this is
a comedic character this is that
character's ideology and not my own so
you want a little autistic license yes
yeah yeah but you don't want to offend
anybody no you don't i like your
approach of you know just putting your
heart on the line and saying hey
i'm sorry i i was trying to do something
creative yeah hey look i'm an active
genius intention was to mess with
anybody's minds or hearts comedians
gotta
break some eggs yeah yeah you know what
i mean yeah there's nothing funny about
an egg just sitting there it's the yolk
all over the face yeah yeah i love it
you get that you break the egg yeah and
you're just hoping that person isn't
vegan comedy is is a a scary thing you
know there are a lot of really talented
people throughout history
who have said you know
drama is easy
compared to comedy what do you think i i
think that there's a lot there you know
why because i'm a strong believer and
this is also me because i do do comedy
like
all my comedy comes from the darkest
places like i feel like to be into
comedy you got to be a person that
doesn't experience some dog dog moments
because comedy stems from that kind of
like to be able to go all the way left
you also have to be able to go all the
way right you know what i mean like it's
just it's polarity so how do you because
i totally agree i just just preach into
the choir right now
how do you
pull from the dark do you think it heals
you afterwards oh my gosh yes
one of my most popular phrases was but
the guy i guess and i used to come up
with these crazy stories of oh you know
i walked into my boyfriend and he was
with another woman but i guess i always
had another girlfriend you know i would
always have some crazy you know story
line attached but the reality the gag
was a lot of the story lines were true
so you're taking like a plucky approach
but really you're saying this rip my
heart out just rip my heart out but here
i am making a joke and you're the joke
and then after the camera cuts i'm like
i admire that i want to see you cry i
want to see you left i think laughter
and crying they're like twins oh they're
twins they kind of look alike they
function alight and it's like you know
what do you want to do you want to laugh
or cry i think you cry enough you got to
turn it to laughter stop crying boo hoo
no more
turn it into your strength and your
power yeah and maybe if you can even
make someone else laugh then that's when
then see that's the thing
it's almost like how when kevin hart
said laugh at my pain it's like laughing
my pain when i know that i'm able to
give somebody joy even in my weakest
moment that kind of turns around and
reminds you to come outside of yourself
it's like it's empowering to you to know
okay you know what i'm not really ready
to smile but if that what i just said
even though it was sardonic and
sardonically witty if it brought joy to
somebody then hell let my life be a joke
man do you think
that people know
how naked and vulnerable comedy is no
no
i don't think they have any clue any
clue you know what i mean again i think
some of our best comedians have been so
honest about dealing with mental health
issues from anxiety to depression and
you know i've also been very candid
about my experience with that and so
much of what i do you know the art is
one of the only if not the only place
i've ever felt seen so at the end of the
day you have to be yourself you know and
own your hardships your triumphs your
losses and express it you gotta express
it whether it's journaling whether it's
writing a song it ain't gotta be a good
song i write songs i hate my life i just
wanna go
away
sometimes you do stuff like that and the
other times you might turn into a
character that you that really just you
know i'm never a mean in my personal
life let me be mean in the character i
love lady miss jaclyn for that because i
get to just cuss people out without
curse words it's great
you have a tattoo the word perception in
small block letters across your left hip
but it's crossed out was that easier
than getting it removed what's the
message
you know why because growing up as an
entertainer the perception of who i was
was always such a hard battle to
overcome or at least it felt that way
especially as i started to get fame you
know it's like one thing to just you
know be an actor working out or doing a
thing but then when fame gets included
in that it really can make things so
shifty and i always felt so burdened by
that and so when i was 21 i was doing um
cinderella on broadway new york actually
really changed my life and it really
helped me a lot where it came to you
know kind of owning who i am and i said
you know what you know let me get
perception tattooed i'm a crossed out
because it means nothing to me i refuse
to let other people's perception of me
to be my perception of myself
so um
what makes you laugh ooh what makes me
laugh anything can make me laugh i'm the
kind of person that laughs mostly though
at the goofy silly jokes like one of my
favorite comedians all the time is jim
carrey yeah oh cause he just
yeah i knew jim carrey back in the day
who else makes me laugh jason bateman
makes me laugh he's so funny like it's a
different humor very dry very dry like i
love it my humor is very wet
his is real real real dry it's like
sandpaper
and like a viscous jelly
you know
that's what i think now say it's late
night you're getting home from the
comedy clubs and bargain you know comedy
basements and uh you wanna eat some food
what are you gonna eat i'm probably
gonna get me some tacos you know from
like a little nice little taco truck if
i'm in l.a now if i'm in new york then i
might go ahead and get me some pizzas
specifically from little italy's not the
town like the area but literally the
shop little italy's i like the joe's
pizza okay i know joe oh good i gotta
try the little italy it was so good well
i'll try it late night when it's the
worst time to eat it is my favorite time
i'm wondering as one last thing we do a
tradition here at banana moors because i
don't think that there's anything i love
more than the spit take oh yeah and i'm
wondering if i can put some tea in my
mouth and i'll just hold it in there
until something happens where you make
me have to
not be able to hold it in my mouth
anymore
king kong
so little denzel did it i gotta tell ya
really been looking forward to this
piece
i admire you
i respect you
and we all know what all the fuss is
about we can't wait to watch you on your
journey and cheer you on i applaud you
darling i love you ah and you know i
love you too you're lonely
call me
all right this is mitzi bananamore we've
been kibbitzing with kiki palmer
i hope she calls me
you know what i mean
[Music]
you